LT how are you this morning I'm doing
wonderful dad how are you my friend
don't ok Arian Foster retiring I know at
the age of 30 and banged up but uh you
understand why somebody walks away at
this point I do you know especially
playing that position it's not easy and
over the last you know two or three
years he's battled back from a number of
injuries and I think he really realizes
now that he just will never be able to
stay healthy in the entire season and so
it's difficult and he's probably been
thinking about this dan honesty for the
last two years you know some tough
injuries and I think this was his last
chance to to test his body you know to
see if he can actually do it and you
know listen it is miss you know having
Jay Ajayi rush for 200 yards and
consecutive games you know that in hurt
you know so at that time say okay you
know I think this team is this okay
because initially they brought him and
thinking he's going to be the guy he's
known teach these young guys so he did
that for the first you know what half
the season but I you know I'd applaud
him for doing it you [ __ ] 32 yes
what did you feel like it 32 I still
felt great honestly I still felt like I
can play another two years or so at a
you know at a you know a decent level
being a great third down back change of
pace type of guy um you know but you
know damn my style I didn't take a lot
of big shots you know I never had a
surgery I really never got seriously
hurt out there you know and so comparing
me to how I felt that 32 and maybe what
Aaron is going through it's a little
different 32 though men it's anybody
going to catch em it with his rushing
yards considering it's a pass-happy
league no I don't think so I
you know I thought Adrian Peterson would
have a chance just because he's the type
of guy that had the mindset to continue
to play for you know 14 15 years I think
he has that mindset and you know the way
he plays obviously you know electrifying
and he turns out you're seems every year
whenever he plays but now obviously the
problem is the injuries are starting to
accumulate on AP and so we don't know
what we're going to see over the next
year or two from ATP you know what I
mean like this could be one of those
things that you know kind of slow him
down some yeah I wonder if he's played
his last down in Minnesota i I just I
don't know if he's going to be back on
that team and then if somebody picks him
up what role do they because Minnesota
was going to use him they were going to
run him with Teddy Bridgewater being so
young and now with Sam Bradford there
we're not even sure if Bridgewater comes
back so I don't know what that means for
Adrian Peterson we're talking to
ladainian tomlinson the NFL network if I
gave you the Patriots of the field right
now what would you take I would take the
Patriots yeah I definitely would take
the Patriots and you know this is not
surprising honestly we have a motivated
Tom Brady who feels like he has
something to prove and you know he has
that mindset you know of to kick you
when you're down you know if I'm the
iron I want to dominate every single
play he has that mindset and that
permeates throughout the team you know
his attitude and the way they approach
things combined with you got the best
coach in the National Football League
and Bill Belichick the way they are able
to not only prepared everybody prepares
for a game but the difference is two
adjustments at halftime you know
different situations throughout the game
that's where they are head and shoulders
over everybody else do you think Philip
Rivers retires a charger I really do uh
you know I don't see the charges you
know they love Phillip in
you know he's a franchise guy he's their
franchise guy I really don't think they
are interested in you know in moving
Phillip bar or even you know try get rid
of him at the end of his career I just
think this is one of those situations
where he plays his entire career in San
Diego but is there a part of him that
wants to go on you know wants to go out
as a winner he's going to put up
unbelievable numbers but is there a part
of Philip who's such a competitor that
he's going to say you know get me some
place where I have a chance to win a
title you know that's interesting that
you say that then and a part part of me
and I don't know this for sure part of
me I feel like um a number of year what
two or three years ago remember when
that was just trade talk about him going
to tennessee and you know they you know
do the trade and all i think at that
time he probably felt like that I think
but now I don't think he feels like that
anymore I think he feels he wants to
make it work in San Diego and they're
not they're not fall off from from being
a team to compete in that division and
when that division gone and playing the
playoffs I that's the way Philip thinks
I believe he's at that place now but yes
a few years ago I think he was thinking
you know what I might want to move and
and try to go somewhere else people ever
want to try to tackle you yeah yeah of
course of course people you know you
know because I think when people see me
out in public you know they can't do it
like man you you are you're bigger than
I thought you were you know because they
don't think I'm some small guy you see
me on TV playing next to these 66
300-pound linemen of course I look small
you know but in average size you know
I'm not very small did you ever let him
try to tackle you know I still got a
mini Stefan oh really yeah man how that
kind of never goes away you know how
about it to super bowl I got one of my
den ends here Paulie
maybe you know you can wear full pads
he'll wear full pads and then it just
takes a pop at you do you ever miss
getting hit um you know I missed the
physical nature of that you know part of
challenging your body that I do miss
that part of it because there was
nothing there was nothing like that the
challenge physically of if your body can
take certain punishments are certain
hits um you know but there are other
ways to you know to get that feeling and
you know us are you proud you know MMA
stuff practicing that type of stuff you
know kind of it it helps from missing
that part of the game how would you have
done in the Octagon if you devoted your
career to it I think I would have been
great because the one thing about it you
know it all starts with athletic ability
right you know and so if you're able to
you know if you have the athletic
ability then you can train your body to
do whatever it needs to do right and so
if I dedicated myself to MMA and really
training to do it I think I would have
been been excellent because of my
athletic ability why don't you take on
Herschel Walker no I think that for
Herschel Manny's is a different caddy I
mean he's a freak he would accept that
you know he would be like break it all
else would you want to get in with conor
mcgregor no not on me yeah I don't think
there will ever be a chance I'm much
bigger than Connor you know but you know
Connor is uh could you take him
absolutely not oh I made not at this
point what about Jane Glazer how about
you and Jay Glazer I probably still take
j-james pretty tough though but you know
I think now Jay has been doing it what
about 15 years now I mean he's you know
it will that would that would be fun I
would like to see I would like to see
what I happy I'd like that too hey all I
don't talk to you during the regular
season see you in Houston at the Super
Bowl yes sir great great to talk to you
again LT
thanks Dan ladainian tomlinson the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience